hello there reject nation of Greggy Elba
John Humphrey we are going to watch
today a video called an unhelpful guide
to kpop sure it's a bit dull this is a
top award tier video requests from
patron Laura Moore who has requested BTS
in the past and she specifically said
all I've sent you was BTS and I want to
do more than that when I joined top tier
so here's my request for the month I had
already decided on yeah don't really
think of it as a guide and they're more
like guidelines yeah the only thing it
was a guide and more as just the best
way I could find to let you see a lot of
very different kpop in one sitting guys
are patreon where do we cook you a nays
and TV show reactions and Jon does music
video reactions yeah music video
reactions out there sit there watch the
song listen to it move my face around a
little bit and immediately stop I turned
the song up extra loud I make sure the
quality on the song is great no cut so
it's basically piracy now you know we
watched the music video we talked about
the song the song is distorted so it's
not a it's like all BTS can't escape
i watch her a washer I'll watch it a
shirt so I'm gonna watch our left i
watch them too whoa that's cool
[Music]
tEEN TOP nice likes for days you know I
hate you wish I could move like that
Oh activist whose video all those words
are bigotry by the way they say no I'm
just saying American slang oh nice old
school exid
[Music]
BAM with these musical instruments nice
what's up man
[Music]
Super Junior
multicultural
[Music]
I don't know you shan't be lonely one of
your girls
[Music]
it's gonna end this one
[Music]
I want to hear this song school to any
well I've heard this one this is song a
radio play in the states I've heard the
song before as possible
hey pops crossing over big wet nice
Snooper oh man love the 80s era
[Music]
paper wave
[Music]
Frenchman butterfly
[Music]
or actually pleasing to thee you don't
have to pretend to like Oh monster
no these gals are you corrected them on
[Music]
I have that water thing lost her eyes
[Music]
of paint
and there's a real quality standard with
kpop huh yeah
state-of-the-art or throwback
[Music]
hammering ddr back oh yeah that's a
whole new songs gonna be it's my little
butterfly song
yes j-pop sounds like a dinosaur
[Music]
inspiring or sad which one is it
[Music]
meltus refer to this emotions Oh what
can't don't
[Music]
the Astro
[Music]
the private school kid Gryffindor's
great Ruby the one girl in our all-boys
school
[Music]
her so many different artists oh did we
see was that a real no does it all again
[Music]
g-dragon what is this okay ready
you can worked in I agree
like I have their body
[Music]
oh I got back to guys heart attack
oh nice [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ]
catchy though huh
doom
[Music]
my god whoa
I'm not gonna lie this my favorite
section so far yeah watch all of these
now oh oh whoa Conan O'Brien what
don't cut away sigh how old is this guy
I don't know but he's the Gangnam style
guy
[Music]
can be recovered
[Music]
as a big pencil I love comically large
[Music]
strawberry do
[Music]
getting you a red gun no I just the
music video collection we've seen this
one yeah yeah go there's our boys the
place in my heart that just feels at
home when they start singing yeah they
can let our first one our first one
well my first one this isn't my personal
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
beats me yeah you're telling me
BTS when you get insane whoa
[Music]
Oh karaoke song that okay
so hang it over defend they cut it over
I'll paint for that Beach
monster
[Music]
but
[Music]
oh we don't get to see the twist like
most of these said they're pretty
colorful I know that's cool doubt
Rubik's Cube dimension
[Music]
as a cool
[Music]
yep
[Music]
Sweeney Todd
[Music]
order bass should be a kpop maze
overnight
[Music]
fascinating there was a ghost
[Music]
maybe that this proof whoa Wow
it seems like the more members you have
the better the company not enough
members
[Music]
Gangnam style has got to be a No
[Music]
God lets Arowana kpop sexy
[Music]
yeah oh poor button okay
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
and I know all these songs I've heard a
lot about this song but I've ever heard
[Music]
[Music]
well
and whites right on oh yeah yeah we know
this one you watch this one too
[Music]
[Music]
whose whale wale Twilight yeah busted on
the scene like back in college I think
I'm not sure I couldn't really describe
his music too
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[ __ ] feet bastards
[Music]
what is happening in this video
hey-ho hey-ho
[Music]
and this is Rock mannequin event yeah
definitely
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
they're always kind of respectful like
everything army wears army I want to see
army there's more than army that's what
the fandom looks like blinky lights it's
gotta be so moving to hear your songs
sung back at you from a stadium I would
be like you're ruining it that you're
here
see me
[Music]
some water
[Music]
BTS army
you are welcome thank you for making
this compilation yes and steering us
through the back Elias okay papa
this comes from the channel moonlight
DOB D Dhabi DOP so I've learned that
there's more than just BTS out there oh
there's like one or two other groups
okay yeah some of them have late ladies
in them and some of them have 13 members
some of them have Conan Conan and flashy
colored music videos it's funny reading
the descriptions of the kinds of
categories I'm like isn't that just
music in general yeah yeah we're sad
some we're happy some are inspired but
it does open up this wide array of a
consistency that you see displayed
throughout like in terms of their music
videos they're all so visceral and
colorful and wonderfully creative and
kinetic yeah they're they're really
experienced they they really create and
they're all amazing dancers apparently
except for the few little like very rare
it here where you see oh they're they're
holding a guitar and drums
that's fell down yeah it's so it's super
duper rare like the categories are
pretty broad or very general but you do
get this immersion in this world of no
this is something that is very real
especially I like wooden terms of
editing capping off with the fandom with
American artists or bands I don't really
consider them to have fandom when
technically it's what they have and we
have fans you have a fan Dave Matthews
differently as a family there's
something that seems weirdly more and
maybe because we're not from Korea
there's something that feels like
massive about their fan base yeah it's
so personal and connected to their
family because it's like an emotional
investment it seems like it's all around
with all these groups seems like people
just yeah door or the music or kpop in
general yeah my ear has
difficult time discerning why this one
is completely different than this one
you know I have a hard time completely
differentiate and then but it seems like
the quality of performance the ability
to sing the ability to dance what you
provide on your music videos especially
I love the weird ones yeah those seem to
be consistent so yeah this is pretty
crazy the world of kpop is a lot more
massive than I realize I thought it was
only like a few groups oh no I mean kpop
inand you know they even touched on
people making songs in Japanese and I
know BTS has done that a number of times
because a j-pop market is also really
huge and I think some would say even
bigger which is kind of hard to fathom
from here and I thought it was
interesting because the more of these
videos we see I don't know how it
actually is in Korea concerning this
stuff but I get the sense that the music
video as a art form and as a part of the
music experience is like really integral
where is here music videos are events
like some of the time you know but it's
a feels fewer and further between to me
whereas here yeah it seems like every
group has like the top production value
and they're going for like crazy shots
multiple locations and you know people
grow over time whether visual effects
are consistently impressive yeah and
like pyro and stuff like that it's
fascinating and also I mean the video
started out by saying that kpop is a lot
of different things and I almost wonder
if kpop the term is restrictive or
reductive in the sense that if there are
so many genres that can fit underneath
it it seems like it's sort of an
umbrella of sorts because they even
brought up some people in here who were
more just like traditional bands at
least a couple in both the girl group
and the boy group side you know playing
instruments and still pop with the
sensibilities but not necessarily with
the same production styles in the same
instrumentation yeah so I almost feel
like in a way it's just the way you
describe music coming out of Korea yeah
I mean I don't want it to be
misunderstood of what I meant by I have
a hard time discerning what makes this
group different and unique than this
other group other than like every member
brings their own unique yes I get that
oh yeah and I don't want it to sound
like I'm saying all kpop music sounds
the same that's not what I'm saying
no ever down
a wide variety of different genres
within there it's not like I didn't say
one like Jack Johnson one artist right
most of his songs I get the same vibe
from yeah kpop yeah but I'm saying that
you kind of get generally the same thing
from him and I and I love that I mean
just from being really immerse into BTS
I've seen there a wide variety of genre
and different kinds of songs and they're
not all the similar sounding one so when
I was making fun of like the
generalization of the categories of them
oh yeah that's that's I mean it's all
music yeah yeah but I think it is good
to acknowledge that though because I
feel like people can generally chalk up
kpop to one sounding kind of song and
they all kind of sound that way if
you're not familiar with kpop and this
really does go out of its way to
demonstrate there is a wide variety of
options to explore an experience within
the kpop world yeah and I mean to be
fair like in this video we saw a number
of songs and groups who are probably
competing in the same Lane so I feel
like what people automatically think of
is that very popular style like these
hard-hitting kind of hip-hop inspired
beads with heavy synth and then these
big melodies and and you know rapping
thrown in okay I got amazing beats they
gig that's B I'm sitting here going like
who's producing all this stuff cuz I
know like you know BTS from what we've
seen at least some of those guys produce
the songs themselves yeah I got to
imagine that some of our producers are
going over to Korea and working with
those artists yeah so I wonder how much
cross-pollination there is well this is
great these guys make sure to subscribe
to moonlight do be Laura more thank you
so much for this video this cool I mean
there were certain groups that I was I
want to go back through this and like
there were songs I was hearing on I want
to hear this whole song yeah and I
definitely want to see at Conan O'Brien
music video or when are you gonna get in
a k-pop you know that's what you really
want to do put everything else you're
doing on hold personal life whatever
career you currently have and start
pursuing a kpop career first learn
Kurian you might want to start there and
then eventually I'd say start solo and
then branch off branch off from being so
long yes see where that goes
it hurts me that sentence makes sense
John don't make fun of me okay well just
call me when you're making that Conan
whiskey commercial